[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
global national begins tonight with what
the democrats have been chomping at the
bit for
after days of relentless ballot counting
joe biden will officially become the
46th president
of the united states many biden
supporters hit the streets to celebrate
and one crowd in new york wasted no time
bidding farewell
to donald trump
but the republicans aren't in any rush
to leave
and trump who was golfing this morning
before he officially lost
refuses to concede good evening and
thank you for joining us
it's been an election like no other and
what a week it has been
joe biden can finally take on the role
he's been coveting for decades
the president of the united states the
key to his win
pennsylvania and nevada he surpassed the
270 electoral votes to win the white
house
with 290. biden has long been keeping an
eye on the prize he first launched his
bid for the white house in 1987. he got
as far as vice president for two terms
now come january he will be sworn in as
the 46th president
but donald trump isn't going gently into
the night his legal team is looking at
all options
to keep him in office we'll get to that
in a moment
but first let's go to global's far
nasser now pharah you've been in
washington
all week for this election what's the
mood like on the streets in the capitol
robin we've been here for 10 days and
it's felt pretty sleepy but today
it was like a pressure valve was
released on this city full of democrats
people were honking their horns popping
champagne one african-american man told
me
finally i can breathe now it took a
while to get to this point
and in a few hours we're going to be
hearing from the new president-elect
jennifer johnson reports it is now
official
joe biden is america's president-elect
biden has spent days appealing for calm
after a long anxious wait we have to put
the anger
and the demonization behind us it's time
for us to come together as a nation to
heal
it's not going to be easy we have to try
hundreds celebrated outside the white
house which was walled off before the
election
president trump had left to go golfing
biden supporters cheered and danced in
the streets across the country
we're so excited we're so excited
america spoke
we won we won every ball counted
before noon saturday biden officially
won pennsylvania
that state's electoral votes pushed him
over the needed 270 mark
to clinch the election they've given us
a mandate for action
on covet the economy climate change
systemic racism they made it clear
they want the country to come together
not continue to pull apart
this is a history-making moment for vice
president-elect kamala harris
who has become the first woman and first
person of black and south asian descent
to become vice president we did it we
did it joe
you're gonna be the next president of
the united states
millions demanded change over chaos but
the election was close
and many trump supporters are angry joe
biden's job to heal the country
has just begun this election was
remarkable for a number of reasons but
one fact stands out
over 74 million americans voted for the
biden harris team
more than any other presidential ticket
in u.s history
jennifer johnson global news washington
let's bring in our washington bureau
chief jackson proskow now
jackson while there's jubilation on the
streets of america and major cities
there's also a tinge of doubt
what are the signals that this isn't
going to be a smooth transition
well first and foremost the president's
own words pharah i mean the fact that he
is refusing to
concede the election at this point
defying tradition that when a winner is
essentially proclaimed you call and
concede trump hasn't done that yet and
there's no indication of if
or when he might actually do that and
we're 74 days out from the inauguration
and i think the question is first and
foremost when does reality strike trump
that he will be leaving the white house
and secondly how does he act in that
time period does he work with the
incoming biden administration
to make things easier or does he throw
up roadblocks does he create chaos along
the way
and then what about the pressing matters
facing the country the pandemic for
example which is surging to
awful new records in deaths and cases
and hospitalizations
does he care to manage that or does he
leave a mess for joe biden to clean up
far those are all questions that we just
don't have the answers to yet
certainly no some will argue that
america has always been divided jackson
but
trump did exacerbate those differences
so what legacy does he leave
with trumpism remember that you know
more than 70 million people voted for
him
well this is the tricky dance that
republicans find themselves in right now
they're not exactly rushing to back the
president's baseless claims that the
election was stolen from him through
some sort of
massless fraud uh but they're also not
exactly you know rushing out there to
congratulate joe biden
either and the longer they wait to
simply acknowledge the natural process
that we're in now
where donald trump is leaving the white
house the harder it's going to be for
republicans to rein in those 70 million
trump supporters
especially the die hard ones and start
planning for any sort of post-trump era
in other words
if they don't deliver that reality check
right now if they don't indicate that
this election was legitimate
there are going to be a lot of angry
trump supporters who are getting more
and more fired up by the day
as the president keeps tweeting out
these claims and tries to make this
false claim for fraud
which just isn't materializing and maybe
that's the natural conclusion here farah
maybe when the fraud claims
officially have not materialized it will
be over we just don't know right now and
that's why republican silence is so
deafening right now
you know in some ways jackson this isn't
the the victory that the democrats
envisioned when it comes to the other
branches of government so how is that
going to complicate things
well it all comes down to georgia in
january a dual runoff for the senate
will determine whether or not democrats
control the senate if they do it helps
them push ahead
with their big plans if they don't it's
all about compromise
to joe biden's credit he has painted
himself as the compromise candidate
willing to work with both sides
okay jackson you now move on on
reporting from donald trump to reporting
on joe biden thanks for your analysis
that is our washington bureau chief
jackson proskow and now for the rest of
our america votes 2020 coverage
let's go over to robin at our global
national news desk robin
all right thanks for that pharah biden
is the next commander-in-chief but his
path to the presidency isn't expected to
be easy
trump and his team are vowing to fight
the election results
and there are tens of millions of
americans who voted for trump
and still support him mike armstrong has
more on the problems
biden now has on his plate that is
unheard of
donald trump's legal team promised to
keep up the fight with a press
conference held
outside a landscaping company it appears
no one told them before they went out
the networks had called the election for
joe biden
who was a call by all the oh my goodness
all the networks wow
all the networks now it also doesn't
appear the president is conceding
before going to the golf course saturday
morning he tweeted out quote
i won this election by a lot the trump
campaign says it will launch a series of
lawsuits
starting monday apparently in several
states they insist their poll observers
were kept
too far away from seeing the work of
poll counters
making those ballots illegitimate how
many are they suggesting
well here in pennsylvania everything
counted after election day
gee just about the 700 000 votes
that president trump was ahead by two
days ago that disappeared
now trump's lawyers are not presenting
actual proof of systemic fraud or
anything widespread
only anecdotal stories about single
cases of alleged impropriety
or basically violations of transparency
it is very unlikely to have an impact on
the results
that doesn't mean trump supporters
aren't pushing for the fight to continue
there's a lot of questionable things i
shouldn't be calling this election
there's
dozens of lawsuits all over the united
states right now they should resolve
those up
my reaction personally is i think it's a
little premature it just sounds like
there's going to be multiple states with
recounts and an awful lot of litigations
in washington the white house has
confirmed chief of staff mark meadows
has tested positive for the coronavirus
meadows has often appeared without a
mask at events he's even refused to
speak to reporters with a mask
on i'm not well i'm not going to talk
according to reports there are four or
five other new cases in the white house
as well
donald trump still has 74 days as
president and during that time the
response to the coronavirus
will still fall to him this country has
struggled during this pandemic
over the last week they've averaged more
than a hundred thousand
new cases a day and sunday they're
likely to hit a new
milestone their 10 millionth case
of coven 19. robin mike armstrong in
philadelphia thanks mike
despite the pandemic americans across
the country are taking to the streets to
celebrate
michigan delivered an essential state
win to make biden's presidency possible
and that's where we find our jeff's
simple tonight jeff what's the mood like
where you are
robin we are here in downtown detroit
michigan and as you can see
it's a bit of a party going on some
people even dressed up for the occasion
there are about 100 people here who have
gathered
from across this region to celebrate
what they see
as a historic victory here the democrats
claiming the white house and reclaiming
their so-called blue wall the states of
michigan
as well as pennsylvania and wisconsin
that handed trump the keys to the white
house back in 2016
but this time are the same states to
evict him going back
democrat blue thanks in no small part to
cities like detroit you know it's
interesting when you look at the numbers
not a lot of people switch sides joe
biden didn't turn
a lot of republicans but he turned out a
lot of democrats especially in urban
cities
like this one we encouraged people to
get out the boat
and clearly that's what they did when i
heard the news i was in my car and i
actually cried
it was emotional for me maybe for four
years we can have
normalized relations with canada again
so a celebratory atmosphere here
a lot of dancing but still a lot of
lingering trepidation
people here have heard that the
president is refusing to concede not
accepting the results of this election
and many of his supporters are following
his lead
i'm worried about the people accepting
some of the falsities that trump is
talking about
and i am worried about potential
violence but the president spent his
term
sowing distrust in institutions and in
the media
and at this critical juncture many of
his supporters say they simply don't
trust
this election result robin jeff several
in detroit tonight thanks jeff
the new administration will obviously
have an impact on the canada
u.s relationship the liberals have been
dealing with an unpredictable president
for the last four years
abigail beeman looks at how biden and
justin trudeau
will make it work abigail the prime
minister's office tells us
president-elect joe biden and justin
trudeau will speak by phone
soon but it won't happen until sometime
after biden speaks
saturday night meanwhile congratulations
are pouring in here north of the border
for both biden
and vice president-elect kamala harris
in a statement justin trudeau said the
canada u.s
relationship is unique on the world
stage and he looks forward to working
with the new administration as
quote we tackle the world's greatest
challenges together
trudeau included covet 19 climate action
and economic prosperity on that list
those are all areas to watch as the new
u.s canada relationship develops
biden will be more aligned with trudeau
than trump was on the climate file but
that poses an issue for the keystone xl
pipeline which biden vows to block
trade was particularly volatile under
trump remember the nafta drama
and tariffs on aluminum and steel a
flash point in the trudeau trump
relationship
june 2018 after trump came to canada for
the g7 summit
and called trudeau very dishonest and
weak tweeting about more tariffs
experts are expecting relief from
punitive tariffs but that doesn't mean
smooth sailing if you have gone through
joe biden's
policy program there is a great deal of
friction being introduced in the free
trade
regime aaron edinger is an expert in
both u.s and canadian foreign policy he
points to the protectionist angle in
biden's platform
including reinvestments in
infrastructure that focus on a buy
american plan
this has different effects on different
sectors
of canada's economy managing that
bilaterally
is going to require a ton of diplomatic
energy
in their congratulatory messages the
green and ndp leaders as well as the
deputy prime minister
highlighted the historic nature of
harris's win
as the first woman and the first black
and south asian person to become vice
president
christopher freeland tweeted about
working together to quote
crush this global pandemic and to crack
more glass ceilings
along the way abigail beeman global news
ottawa world leaders are also reacting
tonight
british prime minister boris johnson
sent out a tweet congratulating biden
and harris
saying he's looking forward to working
closely together on shared priorities
germany's chancellor angela merkel
wished biden the best of luck and every
success
and congratulated harris on becoming the
first female vice president-elect
in american history and france's
president emmanuel macron posted this
message saying
we have a lot to do to overcome today's
challenges
let's work together coming up the covet
clamped down
in bc tough measures in a province that
thought it had the virus
under control
turning now to the pandemic cases are
surging there are now more than 35
thousand active cases of kova 19 in
canada
today ontario hit another daily record
with more than 1100 cases in 24 hours
and the situation in quebec is even
worse health officials there reported
another 1200 cases
and 28 deaths
in bc that province is introducing new
restrictions today after another 567
cases were reported today
new public orders go into effect as of
10 pm tonight
for the next two weeks social gatherings
are not allowed
visiting another household is banned
fitness classes are canceled
all workplaces will be required to
conduct active in-person screening for
kovit 19.
there are to be no social gatherings of
any size
with anyone other than your immediate
household be especially vigilant
in small office places in break rooms
and kitchens
this will give us a chance to stop
the transmission to have a break in that
rising
transmission rate that we are seeing
still ahead why canadians are hesitant
when it comes to a coronavirus vaccine
the solution to the pandemic a covid19
vaccine
could be mere months away but
pharmaceutical companies
still have to get approval from health
canada and some canadians are hesitating
on
whether they'll actually take it as
carolyn jarvis reports
it's the speed of development that's
proving to be most important
and for some most concerning
could be first in line i would yes phase
three trial
sign me up no no no there are usually
mistakes when you
typically rush things in general across
the country canadians are polarized on
whether they'll take a coven 19 vaccine
once it's ready
talking about getting a vaccine out in
2021 that is
unparalleled in anything that's happened
before in vaccine history
ipsos polling on behalf of global news
shows a little more than half
54 percent of people agreed that they
would take a covid19 vaccine
as soon as it's approved 61 percent of
canadians believe a vaccine should be
mandatory
but there is some hesitation when asked
about concerns over long-term side
effects
82 percent of us prefer to wait for
reports that the vaccine is safe
and effective before taking it the
situation is analogous when
seat belts were introduced in cars
people said oh seat belts are dangerous
what if i crashed into a creek and
couldn't get out and drowned and it took
a while for people to see oh
lives are being saved by wearing seat
belts and gradually they're more and
more adopted
so these things do take a little bit of
time before any vaccine is released to
the public it will undergo a rigorous
approval process by health canada
what i want to say is that i will get
the vaccine when it's authorized and if
it when it's my time
i have absolute confidence in the health
canada regulatory review process
and health canada will not authorize a
vaccine if it is
if it should not be released out for for
canadians
canada has signed agreements with the
manufacturers of seven different vaccine
candidates
including sanofi pasteur which is
working on a vaccine in partnership with
glaxosmithkline
it says the same steps are being
followed as with any other vaccine
we're not cutting corner otherwise a
vaccine would already be available now
what's important now say those who have
studied vaccine hesitancy
is a robust messaging campaign to share
the data with canadians
so they're informed to make their own
decision there's a saying in vaccination
it's not vaccines that save lives
it's vaccination a vaccine that remains
in a vial
is 100 percent safe but zero percent
effective
carolyn jarvis global news toronto
and you can watch more on the new
reality tonight with dawn of reasons
starting at 7 p.m in most markets
and at 9 pm in alberta
up next biden's right-hand woman how
kamala harris can shape american
politics in the role
of vp
it's quite the moment for america with a
new administration
take the job of vice president kamala
harris is set to become the first woman
and first person of black and south
asian descent to be elected to that role
in the u.s as eric sorensen explains the
california senator says the victory is
about the soul of america
and that the work has only just begun
we are here it is a breakthrough more
than 200 years in the making
kamala harris the first woman who was
also the first black and south asian
female
to be voted vice president of the united
states a phone call with the boss
captured the moment we did it we did it
joe
you're going to be the next president of
the united states
and 56 year old kamala harris will be by
his side
to have someone like her of her
intelligence and depth
and her background in the white house
it's a good day for america a former
high schooler in montreal
a groundbreaking district attorney in
california and a tough-as-nails senator
harris clashed with biden during her
presidential run
but she was always seen as biden's
likeliest pick for vp
after a summer of unrest over racial
injustice harris
was biden's choice as you all know is
smart
she's tough she's experienced
she's a proven fighter opposite the
oldest president in history
harris is expected to be an active vp
she will inject youth
energy and passion in the white house we
have a chance
to choose a better future
for our country the role of vice
president is often viewed as symbolic
more than substantive
but as the first female after 48 male
vice presidents
the symbolism will carry the weight of
expectations and history
today many of us have been waiting for
for four years and it's possible more
history lies ahead
in the last 60 years five vice
presidents if you include biden
have gone on to serve as president of
the united states
eric sorenson global news and that is
global national for this saturday i'm
robin gill
tonight we leave you with the
celebrations across america for joe
biden who has been declared the 46th
president of the united states
after beating donald trump thank you for
watching and i'll see you
see you here tomorrow have a great night